We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When people critique cul-de-sacs, a lot of the time they're actually critiquing the suburbs more generally,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。当人们批评死胡同时，他们往往是在更广泛地批评郊区，
the cul-de-sac has become sort of like the mascot of the suburbs. Like if Suburbia had a flag, it would have a picture of a cul-de-sac on it. I can still remember how strange that word sounded to me. When my mom told me we were moving from the city of Atlanta to the suburbs of Denver,
死胡同已经成为郊区的某种象征。如果郊区有一面旗帜，上面肯定会印着死胡同的图案。我仍然记得当我妈妈告诉我我们要从亚特兰大市搬到丹佛郊区时，那个词听起来有多么奇怪，
and that we'd be living on one of these things. Hey, that's producer Katie Mingle-Dum. I worked this week. Hi, Roman. The cul-de-sac is a French term, literally meaning the bottom of the bag, or the ass of the bag. So it's no wonder the French themselves prefer to use the word impasse. Another fun fact, the plural of cul-de-sac is actually cul-de-sac, but Katie and I have agreed that it isn't possible to refer to them this way,
而且我们将住在这种东西里。嘿，那是制片人凯蒂·明格尔-杜姆。我这周工作了。嗨，罗曼。Cul-de-sac 是一个法语词，字面意思是“袋底”或“袋子的屁股”。所以难怪法国人自己更喜欢用 impasse（死路）这个词。另一个有趣的事实是，cul-de-sac 的复数形式实际上是 cul-de-sac，但凯蒂和我一致认为，不可能这样称呼它们，
without sounding like a couple of ass-backs. It isn't possible to refer to them this way without sounding like a couple of aspects. I've always felt a little embarrassed by my suburban roots, by the cul-de-sac especially, which with its uterine shape and having the word sack in it, gave me the feeling that I spent my early years cuddled and sheltered in an asphalt womb. Living on a cul-de-sac has come to symbolize kind of everything that young hipsters or just people who are who don't see suburbia as the American dream have come to despise and it's taken on the symbolic role. That's Matt Lasseter and I think he just called you a hipster. Yep I think he did. It's
否则听起来就像两个笨蛋。不可能这样称呼它们而不听起来像两个笨蛋。我一直对自己的郊区根源感到有点尴尬，尤其是对死胡同，它那子宫般的形状和包含“sack”（袋子）这个词，让我觉得我早年是在一个沥青子宫里被呵护和庇护的。住在死胡同里已经成为一种象征，象征着年轻的嬉皮士或那些不把郊区视为美国梦的人所鄙视的一切，它承担了一种象征性的角色。那是马特·拉塞特，我想他刚才叫你嬉皮士。是的，我想他是这么说的。它
come to epitomize suburbia both in the myth of the kind of happy nuclear family American dream and in the way that critics condemn it as a facade. Matt teaches a history of the suburbs course at the University of Michigan. And the great age of the cul-de-sac is the 1950s and 1960s. Matt says that by the 70s and 80s our faith in the nuclear family and in the suburban American dream was starting to break down, and it's evident all over pop culture, like in the 1980s classic ET. At the beginning of the film, we learned that Elliot's parents are divorced and his
已经成为郊区的缩影，既体现在那种幸福核心家庭美国梦的神话中，也体现在批评者将其谴责为虚伪的方式中。马特在密歇根大学教授郊区历史课程。死胡同的黄金时代是20世纪50年代和60年代。马特说，到了70年代和80年代，我们对核心家庭和郊区美国梦的信仰开始瓦解，这在流行文化中随处可见，比如80年代的经典电影《E.T.外星人》。在电影开头，我们了解到埃利奥特的父母离婚了，他的
father is down in Mexico with his girlfriend and his mom's there alone and the family sitting around the table and they're very sad. Nothing like that, penis breath! Oh, yes! Sit down! Dad would believe me. Maybe you ought to call your father and tell him about it. I can't use a Mexico with Sally. I can't use a Mexico with Sally. And then ET comes from outer space, you know, almost like a savior figure, to bring happiness back to this sad, broken, suburban family.
父亲和他的女朋友在墨西哥，而他的妈妈独自在那里，一家人坐在桌边，他们非常难过。没什么像那样的，笨蛋！哦，是的！坐下！爸爸会相信我的。也许你应该给你爸爸打个电话告诉他这件事。我不能用墨西哥和莎莉。我不能用墨西哥和莎莉。然后E.T.从外太空来了，你知道，几乎像一个救世主，给这个悲伤、破碎的郊区家庭带来了幸福。
And I think it's really striking in the film the way that Elliott can kind of, can find freedom and excitement in the suburbs by riding his bicycle, you know, to the end of the cul-de-sac, and then beyond into the woods, in the kind of magical friends where the subdivision stops and the wilderness begins. ET is devastating to me, and I get last year's point about E.T. providing the escape hatch to the horrible, oppressive cult asack, but I also think you can't deny the fact that the kids in E.T. ruled the neighborhood. I mean the boys outmaneuver the feds on their dirt bikes. It's a great place to be if you're seven years old and you want to ride your big wheel out in the street,
我认为电影中埃利奥特通过骑自行车，你知道，骑到死胡同的尽头，然后进入树林，进入那种神奇的朋友们所在的地方，即住宅区结束而荒野开始的地方，在郊区找到自由和兴奋的方式，真的很引人注目。《E.T.》对我来说是毁灭性的，我理解拉塞特关于《E.T.》提供了逃离可怕、压抑的死胡同的逃生舱的观点，但我也认为你不能否认《E.T.》里的孩子们统治了社区的事实。我的意思是，男孩们骑着他们的越野自行车智胜了联邦调查局。如果你七岁，想骑着你的大轮车在街上玩，那是个好地方，
but it's not a great place to live, I would argue if you're 14 years old and want to get out of the neighborhood and you don't have a car, then you start feeling trapped. Culdasacks do tend to be isolating. They aren't connected to other streets and they're far away from town centers. But even though culdasacks are experiencing a backlash right now, they were themselves part of a design backlash against urban living and the traditional grid pattern streets that make up most cities. We think about the cul-de-sac-based subdivision and its opposite,
但如果你14岁，想离开社区又没有车，那它就不是一个好住处，你会开始感到被困住了。死胡同确实往往具有隔离性。它们不与其他街道相连，而且远离市中心。但尽管死胡同现在正经历反弹，它们本身也是对城市生活和构成大多数城市的传统网格街道模式的一种设计反弹。我们想到基于死胡同的住宅区及其对立面，
which is the urban grid pattern. But if you go back before World War II, there was a third alternative, which was the early garden suburbs that had curvilinear streets, but they were designed to fit in with the landscape, to create buffers between the houses, to integrate people into parks and lakes and other natural features. And so it was the opposite of the grid pattern, but it wasn't great people into parks and lakes and other natural features. And so it was the opposite of the grid pattern, but it wasn't the coldest sack based
即城市网格模式。但如果你回到二战前，还有第三种选择，那就是早期的花园郊区，它们有曲线形的街道，但它们的设计是为了与景观相适应，在房屋之间创造缓冲区，将人们融入公园、湖泊和其他自然特征中。所以它是网格模式的对立面，但它不是基于死胡同的
kind of into the road dead end pattern. The streets almost always came back around to other streets. It was when the suburbs became mass-produced after World War II that the worst aspects of suburban design began to dominate. Whether or not you buy the idea that cultists acts are psychologically oppressive or stifling to the freedom of those that live there, they have some real quantifiable design flaws. Right, like imagine being a garbage collector or a street cleaner, and instead of driving down one long street and collecting all the garbage from that street and then taking a right onto the next street and so on, you've to turn around and all of these cul-de-sacs
那种进入道路死胡同的模式。街道几乎总是会绕回到其他街道。正是二战后郊区开始大规模生产时，郊区设计最糟糕的方面才开始占据主导地位。无论你是否相信死胡同在心理上是压抑的，或者对居住在那里的人的自由是窒息的，它们确实有一些真正可量化的设计缺陷。对，就像想象一下作为一个垃圾收集员或街道清洁工，而不是沿着一条长街行驶并收集那条街上的所有垃圾，然后右转进入下一条街，以此类推，你必须在所有这些死胡同里掉头
over and over again. It takes more time, you use more gas. They're expensive to maintain, and now some governments, like the one in the state of Virginia, are starting to ban them in all new developments. For many homeowners, when it comes to moving into a new subdivision, they try to find a cul-de-sac because they say it is the best spot to be in. But now, leaders in the Commonwealth are telling developers if they build a new subdivision, they can leave these cul-de-sacs out. Kim Nelson and her two kids moved into this new subdivision eight months ago.
一遍又一遍。这需要更多时间，消耗更多汽油。它们的维护成本很高，现在一些政府，比如弗吉尼亚州的政府，开始在所有新开发项目中禁止它们。对于许多房主来说，当谈到搬进一个新的住宅区时，他们会尽量找一个死胡同，因为他们说这是最好的位置。但现在，联邦的领导人告诉开发商，如果他们建造一个新的住宅区，他们可以省去这些死胡同。金·尼尔森和她的两个孩子八个月前搬进了这个新的住宅区。
She specifically picked this street because it was the cul-de-sac. We like living in a cul-de-sac area because it gives us an opportunity for children to play in a very safe environment. Like many other owners, Nelson says they don't have to worry about speeding cars or streets with a lot of traffic. Wait, who are we calling? My mom. Hey mom.
她特别选择了这条街，因为它是一个死胡同。我们喜欢住在死胡同区域，因为它为孩子们提供了一个在非常安全的环境中玩耍的机会。像许多其他业主一样，尼尔森说他们不必担心超速行驶的汽车或交通繁忙的街道。等等，我们在给谁打电话？我妈妈。嘿，妈妈。
Hey honey. You know, I've been doing all this research about cul-de-sacs. And I guess I'm wondering how you could move our family to such a depraved place. You love to cul-de-sac. Because it was A place where you know you were allowed to go out there all hours of the day and night and play and Be pretty much unsupervised. Oh, she sounds nice She's the nicest and it's true. I did love the cul-de-sac I didn't like school and I didn't fit in there But none of that seemed to matter on the cul-de-sac.
嘿，亲爱的。你知道，我一直在做关于死胡同的所有研究。我想我在想你怎么能把我们家搬到这样一个堕落的地方。你喜欢死胡同。因为它是一个你知道你可以全天候出去玩，而且几乎不需要监督的地方。哦，她听起来不错。她是最好的人，这是真的。我确实喜欢死胡同。我不喜欢学校，我在那里不合群。但这一切在死胡同上似乎都不重要。
On the cul-de-sac, it was all about ghost in the graveyard and finding the guts to launch off the skateboard ramp. And that was a world I shined in. My parents though, they always seemed like they lived there just for me. And after I moved away, eventually they did too. Now my mom and dad live in a new development that urban planners would refer to as mixed use. That's shops and houses and restaurants all mixed in together. They love it. They live right above the gap.
在死胡同里，一切都是关于“墓地里的鬼魂”游戏，以及鼓起勇气从滑板坡道上冲下去。那是我闪耀的世界。不过，我的父母，他们似乎总是为了我才住在那里。在我搬走后，最终他们也搬走了。现在我的父母住在一个城市规划者称之为“混合用途”的新开发项目中。那是商店、房屋和餐馆混合在一起。他们喜欢它。他们就住在Gap商店的楼上。
There's a library within walking distance. My dad helps lead a lecture series in their condo. And I like that as they get older, they won't need to be dependent on a car to get what they need. It's perfect for them. But for a kid? Where do the kids play? Where do they play? Yeah. But one family that I'm thinking of who lives up on the fifth floor, their children are pretty young and they have talked about they go to different parks around the area quite often. Going to parks with mom and dad doesn't sound nearly as cool as taking over an entire
步行范围内有一个图书馆。我爸爸帮忙领导他们公寓里的系列讲座。我喜欢随着他们年龄的增长，他们不需要依赖汽车来获得他们需要的东西。这对他们来说很完美。但对于一个孩子呢？孩子们在哪里玩？他们在哪里玩？是的。但我想到的一户住在五楼的人家，他们的孩子还很小，他们谈到他们经常去该地区不同的公园。和爸爸妈妈去公园听起来远不如每晚占领整条
street every night. It's really a type of suburban development that's organized around the needs of five year olds or eight year olds or ten year olds. Professor Laster argues that we shouldn't be designing our neighborhoods exclusively around the needs of five year olds. And new studies are showing that is gas prices rise and people become more ecologically conscious. We're already seeing a reverse flight back out of the suburbs and into cities. There are even fears that suburbs will turn into ghost town slums and ghettos of the future. I would really give ghosts in the graveyard a whole new edge.
街道那么酷。这确实是一种围绕五岁、八岁或十岁孩子需求组织的郊区开发。拉斯特教授认为，我们不应该仅仅围绕五岁孩子的需求来设计我们的社区。新的研究表明，随着汽油价格上涨，人们变得更有生态意识。我们已经看到了一种从郊区回流到城市的逆向飞行。甚至有人担心郊区会变成未来的鬼城贫民窟和隔都。我真的会给“墓地里的鬼魂”游戏带来全新的边缘感。
Indeed. 99% invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle from the Great Third Coast International Audio Festival to look it up and me Roman Mars. With support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity, it's a project of KALW, 91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the center for architecture and design and the American Institute of Architects San Francisco. To find out more, go to the website. It's 99%invisible.org. Everyone is Roman again. And during this little section of the podcast last week,
确实。本周的《99%隐形》由来自伟大的第三海岸国际音频节的凯蒂·明格尔制作，去查一下，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。在Lunar的支持下，用创造力创造不同，它是旧金山当地公共广播电台KALW 91.7、建筑与设计中心以及美国建筑师协会旧金山分会的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问网站。网址是 99%invisible.org。大家又是罗曼。在播客的这一小部分，上周，
I asked you to review the show and iTunes and maybe go like us over on Facebook. And I was so overwhelmed by the response. It was so sweet and kind and generous. And I think we got like 60 or 70 more reviews last week because of that call out. And over 100 more people on Facebook. So thank you so much. I can't, I mean, it was just amazing.
我请你在iTunes上评论这个节目，也许去Facebook上点赞我们。我对回应感到非常不知所措。它是如此甜蜜、友善和慷慨。我想因为那个呼吁，我们上周多了60或70条评论。Facebook上多了100多人。所以非常感谢。我不能，我的意思是，这真是太棒了。
It was more successful than I ever thought possible. So if you did take the time to review the show, that was really sweet. And if you haven't yet, I'm happy just to have you as a listener. But if I can put you over the edge to write a review, that would be fantastic too. Because I swear, those reviews kept me in the top 50 ranking for arts podcasts all week long and it wasn't because I got some huge spike in downloads.
它比我预想的要成功得多。所以如果你花时间评论了这个节目，那真的很贴心。如果你还没有，我很高兴有你作为听众。但如果我能让你写一条评论，那也会很棒。因为我发誓，那些评论让我整个星期都保持在艺术类播客排名前50名，这并不是因为我的下载量激增。
It was just because of your reviews. That's how it works. It was amazing. So thank you so much. It was so sweet to read the response too. It was really, really beautiful. And the final thing is 99% of visible is now on Stitcher. So, check it out on Stitcher. It's like an iPhone app that that chains together podcasts into little playlists and it actually works really well and it's very fun. And I just wanted more people have a chance to hear it and maybe get new ears.
这仅仅是因为你们的评论。这就是它的工作方式。太棒了。所以非常感谢。阅读回应也很甜蜜。它真的很美。最后一件事是《99%隐形》现在在Stitcher上了。所以，去Stitcher上看看吧。它就像一个iPhone应用程序，把播客串联成小播放列表，它实际上工作得很好，而且非常有趣。我只是想让更多人有机会听到它，也许能获得新的听众。
So if you use Stitcher, I like the show, let's do it again and maybe it'll go up the rankings there too and new people will find it. Alright, thank you so much, I'll talk to you next week. Take care. you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以如果你使用Stitcher，我喜欢这个节目，让我们再做一次，也许它也会在那里的排名上升，新的人会发现它。好的，非常感谢，我们下周再聊。保重。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。